en los vídeos anteriores definimos estas
nuevas variables de movimiento
rotacional y las definimos de la misma
forma en las que definimos las variables
para el movimiento lineal por ejemplo
este desplazamiento angular se definió
de la misma forma que definimos el
desplazamiento regular esta es la
posición angular a diferencia de la
posición regular de manera similar esta
velocidad angular fue el desplazamiento
angular por el tiempo de la misma manera
que la velocidad regular es igual al
desplazamiento regular por el tiempo y
la aceleración angular es el cambio en
la velocidad angular por el tiempo igual
que la aceleración regular es el cambio
en la velocidad regular por el tiempo y
debido a que estas definiciones son
iguales a excepción de que esta variable
regular es reemplazada por su
contraparte angular todas las ecuaciones
resultan de los principios de movimiento
regular y esto se cumple para las
ecuaciones de movimiento rotacional
siempre y cuando reemplazamos la
variable de movimiento lineal
esa ecuación con su equivalente
rotacional y esto también funciona con
las gráficas digamos que tenemos una
gráfica de tiempo contra velocidad que
se ve así y como ya sabemos que la
pendiente de la gráfica en esta gráfica
de tiempo por velocidad es igual a la
aceleración en la gráfica de velocidad
angular contra el tiempo está pendiente
representa la aceleración angular ya que
la relación entre omega y alfa es la
misma que la relación entre b y a de la
misma forma el área bajo la curva en una
gráfica de velocidad contra tiempo
representa el desplazamiento el área
bajo la curva en una gráfica de omega
contra t o una gráfica de velocidad
angular contra tiempo el área bajo la
curva de esta gráfica también va a
representar el desplazamiento angular y
si recuerdan lo que vimos del movimiento
en una dimensión la forma en que
deducimos muchas de las fórmulas
cinemáticas en una dimensión
relacionando estas variables de
movimiento lineal era encontrando áreas
o una gráfica de velocidad contra tiempo
podemos hacer lo mismo con las variables
de movimiento rotacional podemos
encontrar la relación de esta área entre
alfa y omega y obtendremos la fórmula de
movimiento rotacional pero ya las
conocemos y como éstas ya las tenemos
definidas de la misma manera que tenemos
definidas las variables de movimiento
lineal obtendremos exactamente las
mismas ecuaciones símplemente
reemplazando la variable lineal con su
respectiva variable de movimiento
rotacional vamos a escribirlas primero
vamos a escribir las fórmulas de
movimiento lineal que si recuerdan lucen
así aquí están estas son las cuatro
fórmulas cinemáticas que relacionan las
variables de movimiento lineal entre sí
pero recuerden que estas fórmulas sólo
funcionan si a la aceleración es
constante si la aceleración es constante
entonces estas cuatro fórmulas de
movimiento son una forma conveniente de
relacionar todas estas variables de
movimiento lineal y ahora si queremos
las
el movimiento rotacional podrían hacer
lo que hicimos aquí y deducir cada una
de estas fórmulas usando las áreas bajo
la curva pero como ya conocemos las
relaciones de todas estas variables de
movimiento lineal y sabemos que tienen
la misma relación que las de las
variables de movimiento rotacional puedo
tener mis fórmulas de movimiento
rotacional simplemente reemplazando cada
una de estas variables lineales con su
respectiva variable rotacional vamos a
hacerlo aquí en lugar de tener la
velocidad final voy a tener a omega la
velocidad angular final en lugar de
tener la velocidad inicial voy a tener
la velocidad angular inicial y en lugar
de la aceleración voy a tener la
aceleración angular y el tiempo sigue
siendo el tiempo este no cambia no
existe nada como tiempo angular o tiempo
lineal
estáte es única y funciona igual en
ambas ecuaciones y se pueden preguntar
cuándo van a ser ciertas estas fórmulas
de movimiento rotacional
cuando alfa sea constante la aceleración
angular y podemos continuar así en donde
sea que tengamos x que es la posición
vamos a reemplazarla por z que es la
posición angular así que vamos a
reemplazar todas las x por theta
reemplazamos todas nuestras
aceleraciones por aceleraciones
angulares y finalmente reemplazamos
todas nuestras be inicial y be final con
una mega inicial
iomega final y estas son las fórmulas
cinemáticas rotacional es sólo se
cumplen si la aceleración angular es
constante y si es constante estas
fórmulas son una manera conveniente de
relacionar todas las variables de
movimiento rotacional entre sí y podemos
resolver muchos problemas usando estas
fórmulas de cinética rotacional y las
vamos a usar de la misma manera que
usamos estas fórmulas del movimiento
lineal identificamos las variables que
conocemos identificamos la variable que
queremos encontrar y elegimos aquella
fórmula que nos permite despejar nuestra
variable incógnita
a ver algunos ejemplos de problemas que
podemos resolver usando estas fórmulas
ya que necesitamos cierta práctica para
poder usar estas fórmulas con comodidad
copio estas fórmulas que son las que
vamos a usar y vamos a usarlas para
resolver algunos problemas de cinemática
rotacional nos deshacemos de todo esto y
vamos a resolver el primer problema este
problema nos dice que tenemos una barra
de 4 metros de longitud y es lo que he
tenido aquí todo el tiempo y pueden ver
que puede rotar y comienza a rotar a 5
revoluciones con una aceleración angular
constante de 30 radiales por segundo al
cuadrado y la pregunta es cuánto tiempo
le lleva a hacer cinco revoluciones qué
hacemos cómo resolvemos este problema
primero tenemos que identificar todas
las variables que conocemos y aquí dice
que rota a cinco revoluciones esta es la
cantidad de ángulo que ha recorrido pero
tiene unidades extrañas están en
revoluciones y nosotros conocemos que es
del tate está cinco revoluciones pero
queremos nuestra delta t está en
radiales
que vean que nuestra aceleración está
dada en 30 radiales por segundo al
cuadrado tenemos que asegurarnos de
comparar manzanas con manzanas por lo
que no puedo tener revoluciones en delta
theta y una aceleración en radiales
tenemos que elegir una unidad y la
unidad que típicamente elegimos son los
radiales cuantos radiales habrá en cinco
revoluciones una revolución es 2 y
radiales porque un círculo completo es
igual a 2 pirra dian es lo que significa
que cinco revoluciones van a tener cinco
por dos por pi radiales lo que nos da 10
y radiales ya tenemos nuestro
desplazamiento angular que otra cosa
conocemos nos dicen que la aceleración
angular es constante y es de 30 radiales
por segundo al cuadrado esta es nuestra
aceleración angular es de 30 radiales
por segundo al cuadrado podemos escribir
los radiales o podemos omitir los a
veces dejan esto vacío y solo poner 1 /
s al cuadrado y es por eso que aquí no
puse los radiales aunque podemos
escribirlo si queremos y está alfa será
positiva o negativa bueno este objeto se
está acelerando comenzó en reposo por lo
que quiere decir que aumentó su rapidez
por lo que la dirección del
desplazamiento angular es la misma que
la dirección de la aceleración angular
es decir si algo está aumentando su
rapidez nos tenemos que asegurar que su
aceleración angular tenga el mismo signo
que la velocidad angular y viceversa y
ya que aquí tenemos 10 y radiales
positivos y el objeto aumenta su rapidez
pues vamos a tener una aceleración
angular positiva si esta barra fuera más
despacio tendríamos que asegurarnos que
está alfa tenga el signo opuesto al de
la velocidad angular pero estas son sólo
dos variables de movimiento rotacional
siempre necesitamos tres variables para
poder encontrar la cuarta y cuál es
nuestra tercera variable cinemática
rotacional pues es que nos dicen que el
objeto comenzó en reposo y este es el
código que indica que la omega inicial
es igual a 0 la velocidad angular
inicial es 0 ya que está en reposo y
esta es nuestra tercera variable
conocida y ahora si ya tenemos 3 y
podemos despejar la cuarta y lo que
queremos conocer es el tiempo cuánto
tiempo le lleva a hacer cinco
revoluciones estas son las variables
involucradas y la forma en la que yo me
doy cuenta cuál es la fórmula que debo
usar es revisar cuáles son las variables
que sí conozco y aquella variable que no
conozco y ver cuál es la variable que no
está involucrada y eso mega final aquí
no está involucrada o mega final así que
voy a usar la fórmula cinemática
rotacional que no involucra a omega
final ponemos esto por acá y veo que la
primera tiene a omega final y esta no es
la que quiero usar ya que no la tengo
involucrada veo la segunda fórmula y
también tiene esta omega final veo la
tercera y en esta no tengo la omega
final así que vamos a usar esta fórmula
la copiamos aquí conocemos delta teta
que
es de 10 y radiales sabemos que omega
inicial- fue cero por lo que todo esto
va a ser igual a 0 0 por t va a ser
igual a 0 y nos queda un medio por la
aceleración angular que es de 30
radiales por segundo al cuadrado
positivo y aquí queremos conocer el
tiempo y no debemos olvidar que aquí el
tiempo está al cuadrado despejamos t
algebraica mente multiplicando ambos
lados por 2 lo que nos da 20 pi y luego
lo dividimos entre 30 lo que nos va a
dar 20 pin que técnicamente son 20 pi
radiales
dividido entre 30 radiales por segundo
al cuadrado y debemos encontrar la raíz
cuadrada ya que tenemos tiempo al
cuadrado pero lo que nos preguntan es el
tiempo y si calculamos esto nos queda
que el tiempo es igual a 1.45 segundos y
nuestras unidades se cancelan como deben
hacerlo radiales con radiales estos
segundos al cuadrado pasan al numerador
y el cuadrado se cancela con la raíz
cuadrada por lo que nos quedan segundos
al final
segunda parte del problema nos pregunta
cuál es la velocidad angular después de
rotar cinco revoluciones hay dos formas
en las que podemos resolver esto ahorita
encontramos el tiempo es decir conocemos
todas las variables excepto la velocidad
angular final por lo que ahora puedo
usar cualquiera de estas y para mí la
primera es la más sencilla no tenemos
nada elevado al cuadrado ni alguna
proporción involucrada por lo que
podemos decir que omega final va a ser
igual a omega inicial que es cero más la
aceleración angular que es de 30 y como
conocemos el tiempo podemos decir que es
de 1.45 segundos lo que me da una
velocidad angular final de 43.5 radiales
por segundo
esta es la rapidez con la que esto está
rotando al momento de alcanzar las cinco
revoluciones este es un ejemplo ahora
vamos a ver otro vamos a llevarnos
nuestras fórmulas cinemáticas
rotacionales quitamos todo esto y ahora
tenemos que
de cuatro metros de longitud inicia con
una velocidad angular ahora no está en
reposo inicia con una velocidad y
desacelera con una desaceleración
constante hasta detenerse después de
haber rotado 20 revoluciones y la
primera pregunta es qué tan rápido se
mueve al inicio el borde de la barra en
metros por segundo
en otras palabras este punto de la barra
va a tener cierta velocidad hacia acá y
nosotros queremos conocer cuál es esta
velocidad al inicio en metros por
segundo esto no es muy difícil tenemos
una fórmula que relaciona la rapidez con
la rapidez angular tomamos la distancia
del eje hasta el punto en donde queremos
determinar la rapidez y lo multiplicamos
por la velocidad angular lo que nos va a
dar la rapidez de ese punto tengan
cuidado porque está r siempre va del eje
y aquí tenemos el eje a partir del eje
la distancia hasta el punto en donde
queremos medir la rapidez
que es de hecho la longitud de esta
barra por lo que será de 4 metros y para
encontrar la rapidez decimos que es
igual a 4 metros ya que queremos conocer
la rapidez de este punto que se
encuentra a 4 metros del eje y lo
multiplicamos por la velocidad angular
que al inicio era de 40 radiales por
segundo y nos queda que la rapidez en
este punto a 4 metros del eje es de 160
metros por segundo lo que es bastante
rápido y este es el punto más rápido en
toda esta barra si quisiéramos conocer
la rapidez de la barra en el punto que
está a la mitad sería la mitad del del
extremo ya que nuestra r de acá sería de
2 metros medidos desde el eje hasta este
punto y mientras más nos acerquemos al
eje más pequeña se volverá a esta ere
por lo que también la rapidez será menor
por lo que estos puntos de aquí de la
barra no se van a mover muy rápido
debido a que su erre va a ser muy
pequeña todos estos puntos tienen la
misma velocidad angular es
todos rotan el mismo número de radiales
por segundo pero la distancia del
círculo en el que viajan es diferente
por lo que su rapidez va a ser diferente
y así respondemos la parte a qué tan
rápido se mueve al inicio el borde de la
barra en metros por segundo y fue de 160
metros por segundo y la segunda parte
nos pregunta cuál es la aceleración
angular de la barra y para esta vamos a
tener que usar una fórmula de cinemática
rotacional ponemos estas aquí y
nuevamente tenemos que identificar qué
es lo que sabemos y sabemos que la
velocidad angular inicial es de 40
en esta ocasión conocemos un mega
inicial que es de 40 radiales por
segundo esto gira a 20 revoluciones que
es del tate está pero nuevamente no
podemos escribir directamente 20 ya que
queremos esto en términos de radiales
para poder usar las fórmulas cinemáticas
rotacional es todo tiene que tener las
mismas unidades por lo que multiplicamos
20 revoluciones por 2 pi radio
por revolución lo que nos da 40 y
radiales y que es la tercera cosa que
debemos conocer recuerden que siempre
debemos de conocer tres elementos para
poder usar las fórmulas cinemáticas
rotacionales y el dato es que nos dicen
que desacelera hasta detenerse y cómo se
detiene quiere decir que o megas final
es igual a cero y queremos la
aceleración angular que es alfa y es lo
que queremos conocer y estas son las
variables que queremos usar para conocer
la fórmula que voy a usar tengo que
darme cuenta cuál es la variable que no
está involucrada aquí y en este caso es
el tiempo no me están dando el tiempo ni
tampoco me están preguntando el tiempo y
ya que ésta no está involucrada puede
buscar aquella fórmula que no tiene al
tiempo en ella no es la primera no es la
segunda tampoco la tercera es la cuarta
vamos a usar esta fórmula la ponemos
aquí y sabemos que omega final es cero
sería cero al cuadrado pero cero al
cuadrado sigue siendo cero esto es igual
a omega inicial- al cuadrado que es 40
radiales por segundo al cual
2 más 2 por la aceleración angular que
es nuestra incógnita
así que alfa la dejamos como variable y
de la teta sabemos que es 40 pi radiales
ya que eran 20 revoluciones y si
despejamos algebraica mente alfa movemos
el 40 al otro lado los restamos por lo
que nos queda menos 40 radiales por
segundo al cuadrado y esto lo dividimos
entre este 2 por 40 pi radiales
lo que me da menos 6.37 radiales por
segundo al cuadrado porque es negativo
pues porque esto se fue desacelerando
hasta detenerse por lo que esta
aceleración angular debe tener el signo
opuesto al de nuestra velocidad angular
nuestra velocidad angular inicial era
positiva por lo que la aceleración
angular va a ser negativa en resumen
estas son las fórmulas cinemáticas
rotacionales que relacionan entre sí las
variables de movimiento rotacional y
sólo se cumple si
a la aceleración angular es constante y
cuando es constante podemos identificar
las tres variables que conocemos y
aquella variable que desconocemos y
usamos la variable que no está
involucrada para identificar cuál es la
fórmula que vamos a usar ya que usaremos
la fórmula que no tiene la variable que
no está involucrada aquella variable que
no nos fue dada ni tampoco nos preguntan
por ella